I got something to tell you
you know typically we have gone to the
Reddit Forum to find their mid-a-hole
quandries but I think it's a lot more
fun to actually get ones from our
audience so that so I'm speaking to the
the a-hole related you know moral
dilemmas that you have in your own life
so we got a few today some of them a
little bit complicated
we'll see what we can do figure out who
the a-holes are this is from Cass it
says so I'm a college sophomore who
rushed for a fraternity last fall at my
SEC School hoping to get into the same
fraternity as two of my really good
friends so I gotta stop to hear Cass and
unfortunately you're already the a-hole
because you started the sentence with so
uh that's one of my
I was gonna say one of my major pet
peeves with every pet peeve I have is a
major one to me so that's a distinction
that is not necessary you don't need to
start with so you jump right in I don't
need so I'm a college sophomore I'm a
college sophomore get right into it
you're sweating relax take a deep breath
okay I had rushed my freshman year
unsuccessfully and it really hurt me
pretty badly it took me a long time to
get back on my feet I decided to try
again because my friend said I had a
shot
they agreed to help me along the way
after I rushed unsuccessfully again and
was hurt again I found out my friends
knew that people were trashing me in a
group chat if I knew I probably wouldn't
have hurt my pride again and risked
embarrassing myself I got really mad at
them and told them that they betrayed me
and that our friendship could not go
forward without changes did I overreact
am I the a-hole
um so there's uh I just began a sentence
with so now that I've said that I have
to watch myself for the rest of the
segment more information is needed
that's the problem here it's so it's
going to be hard to sort through this
for one thing you say that your friends
knew that you were being trashed behind
your back obviously in a group chat when
you say trashed what does that mean does
that mean that
people were having a conversation and
you entered into the conversation and uh
people said some things that were
critical the problem is that that
happens to all of us like if you're a
human being who exists physically in the
world and you have relationships and you
know people then you are going to enter
into conversations when you're not there
and some of the things that are said
about you even by people who you think
are close to you are not always going to
be flattering that's the reality and
sometimes it might be because like maybe
you acted like a jerk today and so after
you're gone people like oh what was his
deal what a jerk
that happens you can't really blame
people for that there's a difference
between that and and people engaging in
full-on Gossip where they it's like a
recreational Pastime for them to tear
you down they enjoy it that sort of
thing and if that's what's going on then
okay that's that that does qualify as
they're trashing you behind their back
then the next question is were your
friends participating in that
now you're upset that they didn't tell
you about it but it's not always
necessarily the right thing for someone
to tell you when other people are are
trashing you there are times when maybe
you're not around and there's a
conversation that's had about you it's
not very flattering someone as close to
you is aware of it or made aware of it
or they overhear it it's not always the
right thing for them to track you down
and say guess what people are saying
about you what'd you say because it
sounded to me like you're talking that
in itself is a form of gossip and there
might not be a lot you can do with the
information and it's just going to make
you feel bad there's no reason you have
to know so but there are circumstances
where you do need to know so these are
all these things that I it that's what
makes it hard to sort through if these
friends were engaging in this trashing
they're taking part in it taking Delight
in it then they're not your friends at
all and I I wouldn't there's no making
changes to the Friendship if you have
the kinds of friends who enjoy cutting
you down when you're not around then
they're not your friends now if they cut
you down when you're there then that
just makes that that makes them good
male friends in fact I saw someone
making this point I think it was on
Twitter yesterday that was really good
point that this is like male friends a
real male friend is someone who makes
fun of you to your face but then roots
for you behind your back they might not
be comfortable like telling you all
their feelings to your face but they
they want to see you do well and they're
rooting for you but when you're with
them you guys just make fun of each
other that's just that's like that's a
guy thing you're so old you make dust
look like a baby but if they're cutting
you down behind your back then they're
not friends at all so these are all I
don't know I guess I need to say
undecided on this one and I guess we I
that that's it I need more information
um from Thomas good afternoon all
knowing Sweet Daddy Walsh would I be
able to decline future family gatherings
due to a pest problem this Christmas me
and my wife traveled to the town all of
my close family live at due to their
economic hardships and conditions
there's only one house to actually hold
a gathering while visiting we noticed a
roach problem they weren't everywhere
but they were not avoiding the light or
people which shows a major infestation
growing up my family's house had the
same issue with pests as an adult I keep
my house clean and tidy to avoid this I
like visiting my family and seeing them
but I'll be honest that I was disgusted
when I looked down and saw a roach next
to my shoe my wife grew up on a farm but
she was also taken aback by how casual
my family was with the problem needless
to say we didn't eat dinner while there
so would I be able to decline unless the
problem is fixed uh you're not the ill
for not wanting to eat dinner at a house
where there's a road Devastation they're
not getting hole at all I wouldn't be
able to do that and I also would need to
know so he said this is their house I'm
assuming this is like a single family
type Arrangement it fits enough if
they're living in an apartment complex
type of deal then they could keep their
their part of the overall building
and span and yet there's still going to
be roaches that make their way in
because of all the other rooms in the
and if if the landlord isn't taking care
of the building it might not be their
fault now if you live in a single family
type of home and you've got a major
roads problem then yeah it's because
your house is filthy filthy monsters I
wouldn't give up on them but it is the
kind of thing that I would certainly
bring up to them and say look I you know
I want to see you guys I love to eat
dinner with you but you know it's it's
simply not sanitary is there anything I
could do to help if you're in a position
where you could help them contribute to
get a uh get an exterminator out there
now it's the kind of thing that when you
bring up to someone it's like telling
them they smell bad there's no way to
bring it up that won't be offensive and
it's good they're going to be offended
by it when you tell someone hey your
house is filthy and rosinfest and it
grosses me out they're going to be
offended by that
obviously you're not gonna put it quite
that bluntly but that is the message but
it is something that needs to be brought
because it's not sanitary for them so no
you're not the a-hole hiring used to be
really hard you'd post your job on
multiple sites you'd hope the right
people would see it and then you'd wait
for them to apply it similar to when
you're applying for jobs you search
countless places to find a company that
fits best with your skills and
experience well now there's a place you
can go that makes hiring faster and
easier zip recruiter head to
ziprecruiter.com wall should try it for
free ZIP recruiters matching technology
excels at finding the most qualified
candidates for a wide range of roles see
a candidate you like well you can easily
send them a personal invite so they're
more likely to apply it also gives you a
Competitive Edge against other employers
who may also be interested in that
candidate they're a user friendly
dashboard makes it easy to filter review
and rate your candidates all from one
place see how much easier hiring is with
zip recruiter four out of five employers
I'll post on zipper crew to get a
quality candidate within the first day
see for yourself go to ziprecruiter.com
Walsh to try ZipRecruiter for free again
that's ziprecruiter.com
a-l-s-h the ZipRecruiter the smartest
way to hire
from Joey says Dear Matt am I the a-hole
my parents divorced in late 2018 and in
May of 2019 my mother passed away
growing up my dad expressed his anger
with insults and put Downs along with
screaming towards us but especially my
mother after her death he continues to
talk negatively about her the way she
raises us and her family even pulls my
friends and recently my wife aside and
talks to them about how he thinks my
mother was a bad parent it hurts my very
being I've told him before several times
to stop but he defends his action starts
yelling and hangs up I decided not to
talk to him until he apologizes and
Promises to stop I feel I'm not honoring
my father the way God would want for
context my wife and I are Catholic my
dad is non-practicing I don't hate him
for the unpleasant childhood I'm over it
but it's hard to put up with the verbal
Jabs that my deceased mother or him
talking about her to my friends and
family I'm not sure if my decision to
wait for an apology is childish or
respectful towards my late mother in my
Viejo no you're not day hola your dad
sounds like a great a a-hole himself you
don't and anything at this point yeah we
should honor our mother and father as it
says in the Ten Commandments but that
doesn't mean uh that you shouldn't have
any basic respect for yourself you also
need to honor your wife okay that's
that's that's your first job now as a
married man is to honor your wife before
anyone putting her in a position where
you know she has to endure this is not
okay like this is what I say all the
time about parents you know they they
and I know this now is a parent of six
that it's your job as a parent to
develop a close bond in relationship
with your children that is your job the
onus when your kids are children and
they live in your house the onus is on
you 100 and if your kids leave and uh
and they become adults and they don't
want to have a lot to do with you it's
probably because you didn't do the job
of cementing that relationship in
childhood and that is your fault that
doesn't mean that they should disown you
and never talk to you again but it does
mean that you're probably never going to
have as a parent a really close
relationship even with your adult
children because you didn't as the left
says you didn't do the work
um when you needed to as kids and now
now you're interested now you want the
relationship because they're not kids
anymore and they're easier you don't
have to take care of them and you only
see them in small doses and so it's a
lot easier and you want the fun stuff
you didn't want you didn't want to do
the hard work now you want the fun stuff
it doesn't work that way and so that's
my message to to you know if you're in a
position as the adult child now you
don't owe this like he didn't do
anything to establish a relationship
with you he went the other way he was
abusive and angry and shouting all the
time and now he's cutting down your mom
and he's just being a miserable person
you don't owe him you don't owe him your
time you don't owe him uh your affection
you don't you don't own that so I know
you're not there let's see this from
Justin says I'm 47 but I've always
argued I was in the right on this
incident back when I was in high school
for some reason when I was a junior or
senior my mother thought it'd be funny
to tickle my feet to get me up in the
morning
what this was an extremely torturous
experience but I endured it every
morning as my mother smiled and laughed
at me while performing this daily ritual
while I struggled to drag myself out of
an adolescent Slumber this went on for
five to six months making mornings the
most Dreadful part of the day and then
one day it happened I could not take it
anymore I snapped and shouted knock it
the F off my mother expectedly started
slapping me in the head screaming at me
in horror for what I did it's a
wonderful way to start the day but I
took it gleefully knowing that I finally
said what was brewing in my soul for
months some say that I should have had
more respect for my mom but I endured
this as long as I could for before I
could not take the torture anymore so in
my mind I was justified so I asked is it
me look yeah you are the a-hole because
we were just talking about honoring your
mother and father and uh you know you
don't cuss out your mom period end of
story end of story end of story so you
don't do that so you are the hill for
that on the other hand she does carry
some of the a-hole weight here because I
can't
waking up so someone tickling your feet
every morning for months like that would
actually drive you so I I'm sympathetic
I can see how that would drive you
actually insane
so I understand the frustration I don't
understand her behavior six straight
months
ticklings why would you want to touch
anyone's feet to begin with I like feet
I do not know why six straight months of
that I don't get it but you don't cuss
with your mom you don't do finally from
Haley so for Christmas I got my family a
trip to a cabin about two hours away for
one night we have four kids ages nine to
two as we slept there there was a big
snowstorm that came in and 17 inches of
snow was now in the parking lot I told
my husband we should have brought his
car which has four wheel drive and my
minivan does not but we brought my
minivan after two hours of well I'm
gonna stop you there that's not a
helpful
I don't even know where you're going
here that's not a helpful thing to say
in that situation okay you don't need
after the fact now after the fact you
say well we should have brought the
four-wheel drive
yeah but that how that's not helping
anybody right now like we're all in the
same situation I don't need you after
the fact telling me what we should have
done like it's my fault okay that this
is probably what your husband's thinking
anyway after two hours of trying to get
out of the parking lot the resort people
plowed an area and a bunch of guys came
to push our car my husband was also
pushing
the road above the parking lot wasn't
plowed either there's a little Hill to
get out of the parking lot and as I made
it finally my husband yelled don't stop
keep going so I listened I kept going
and going we had some friends who are
not far in front of me so I called them
pick him up and I kept driving for about
30 minutes
with with his cell phone in my car my
friends called me like 15 minutes later
say they couldn't find him so they went
back to the road driving my way after a
while they found him still running after
my car he ran about three miles with
snow clothes on in a blizzard I felt so
bad
but he said don't stop apparently he
meant don't stop until you get up the
hill but that's not what he said oh wow
who are you like Amelia Bedelia he said
don't stop and you thought like just
drive all the way to Mexico uh I look
he's not in a position where he can give
exact instructions when you're driving
and he's shouting something I don't
think he can get very specific uh who's
a-hole here I mean this is uh we've had
some complicated issues today we've had
some issues where we needed more
information on this one I think would
make it very simple uh that you are you
are the a-hole on this one uh you you
left your husband to run three he's
running after you for three miles in a
blizzard
he was good you had his phone what did
you think he was gonna do
oh man I feel bad for this guy he pushed
you out he's out there he's digging out
he's pushing and you thank him by just
by leaving him and fleeing the state my
God I don't think a-hole even quite
covers it but uh hopefully your marriage
can be repaired after that incident and
look I'm sure you already know this but
uh
this is something he's going to have on
you for the rest of your marriage he's
going to be able to bring this up I'm
not saying that's the most mature way to
to handle a marriage but like we all
have those things and like there are
times
you know in a marriage you should never
bring up past faults but there are also
times in a marriage when you do
something and you know okay that's
coming up again and I probably will
deserve it and this is one of those
times so you are there